des éoliennes en touraine derniers
départements de la région allait refuser
les premiers rangs bien failli être
implanté à nouan les fontaines dont le
maire actuel était alors conseiller
municipal sauf que pendant pratiquement
toute la durée de l'enquêté publique il
ya eu en gros 60 à 70 annotations sur le
cahier des enquêtes publiques qui était
donc avait été favorable il y avait des
favorable mais bon c'était quelque chose
qui s'équilibrent à peu près
correctement et le dernier jour de l'
enquête publique il ya quelques
associations anti éoliens qui sont
arrivés avec à peu près 1200 pétition
signée donc c'était le même document qui
avait été signé par 1200 personnes mais
qui avaient été recrutés dans 25 km
autour
aujourd'hui éric moreau et
vice-président de la communauté de
communes du sud au choix en charge de
son plan climat énergie
il espère que ce territoire accueillant
enfin des éoliennes et plus précisément
à bridoré ou un projet déjà bien avancé
même si l'opposition à l'éolien s'est
manifesté là bas autrement que par des
pétitions au delà de l'agression verbale
dont nous avons eu sur le mât de mesure
qui a été installé donc à la mi juin
stupéfaction un jour les
une entreprise qui vient vérifier
régulièrement le mât de mesure nous
informe d'un sabotage de semaine mesure
ce sabotage
le dévissage de boulons qui tiennent en
sécurité un mât de 100 mètres de haut
aurait pu avoir des conséquences
dramatiques
cet après midi là c'est un tout autre
sujet qui réunit les promoteurs du
projet et des agriculteurs de la commune
les entrepreneurs de l'éolien propose en
effet à tous les agriculteurs
volontaires et pas seulement ceux qui
louent leur terrain le financement d'un
diagnostic territorial et pratiques
agricoles
gs vous avez des budgets pour vous
accompagner
est-ce que vous en avez pas marre
[Applaudissements]
justement vous accompagner mais après
c'est vous qui allez mettre en place ces
visions là c'est aussi une première
ils ont souhaité qu'ils aient un travail
sur la biodiversité plus globale sur le
territoire et donc serrés que ceux des
territoires aussi rires oh que bridoré a
en premier lieu c'est le travail et les
agriculteurs avec pour objectif d'aider
les agriculteurs à s'orienter vers des
pratiques respectueuse de la
biodiversité et en même temps
économiquement soutenable
thierry frémont 154 hectares pour
l'élevage de vaches allaitantes êtes
intéressés par cette démarche alors même
qu'il sait déjà qu'il n'aura pas
d'éoliennes sur ses terres et donc pas
de retombées financières directes
je pense que faire partie d'un groupe
pour
aller plus loin dans la démarche vers
l'environnement est toujours intéressant
est que comme l'ensemble des
agriculteurs sont autour de moi si je
fais pas partie de ce groupe
mon exploitation fera tache dans un
territoire et j'ai pas envie qu'elle
fasse tache et jeu plutôt me tourner
vers la vers l'avenir et l'avenir c'est
je pense une agriculture un petit peu
plus collective le caractère collectif
du projet de ce parc de trois ou quatre
éoliennes
il a d'abord été celui du financement
participatif ouvert aux habitants de la
région pour les études préalables
la finalité pour nous de cette campagne
de financement participatif c'est
pouvoir identifier un petit peu les gens
qui seraient intéressés et moteur pour
finalement leur proposer d'investir
justement dans le capital du futur parc
éolien est finalement qu'ils soient
propriétaires d'un goût des éoliennes et
donc qu'ils bénéficient tous les ans un
des résultats de l'exploitation du parc
éolien aussi c'était march of heroes
tales pour passer outre l'opposition de
la plupart des grands élus du
département face à l'éolien c'est
désormais à bridoré que se tient la
réponse allez on va aller plus loin avec
pierre boucheny vous avez réalisé ce
dossier ce parc éolien pierre at il une
chance de voir le jour à brides aurait
alors tous les cas benoît ça bouge on le
voit dans le sud le choix des élus dans
les communes s'exprime désormais
ouvertement en faveur de l'éolien est
donc ce projet de bridoré arrive à un
moment où le blocage des grands élus de
touraine c'était notamment le cas
d'hervé novelli sur ce plateau ici même
donc il ya quelques semaines
ce blocage donc ne fonctionne plus
totalement quel est le poids aujourd'hui
de l'éolien en région centre ville de
l'éolien c'est 1000 mégawatts de
puissance installée dans la région
centre val de loire donc autant qu'un
réacteur nucléaire est par exemple les
parcs éoliens qui sont implantées autour
de vatan dans l'indre est bien fourni
eux seuls l'électricité nécessaire une
ville de 46 me d'habitants la ville de
châteauroux par exemple alors si on
élargit à l'europe bien il faut savoir
que les énergies renouvelables dans leur
ensemble n'est pas désormais le charbon
en allemagne 40 % d'électricité produite
et cela principalement avec de l'éolien
pierre en france le gouvernement vient
de confirmer que en 2035 le nucléaire
représenterait 50 % de la production
électrique alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est
entre 75 et 80% alors ce serait une
exception française puisque tous nos
pays frontalier à l'allemagne mais aussi
l'espagne l'italie la belgique ont
décidé de sortir du nucléaire totalement
une exception française
qui donne de gros soucis à l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire son patron vient
d'exposer en effet dans une page du
journal le monde
ces motifs d'angoise due au
vieillissement des centrales nucléaires
la plupart d'ailleurs de celles d'autres
régions ont presque atteint la limite de
40 ans et cela va de la corrosion des
pièces de refroidissement des groupes
électrogènes de secours à des
équipements de sûreté
quand été posée à l'envers etc quant aux
réacteurs plus ancien est donc mise à
l'arrêt comme ceux de saint laurent des
eaux à et à 2 est bien le patron de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
s'indigne que leur démantèlement sont
repoussées au siècle prochain bien il ya
encore une dernière question la gestion
la problématique de la gestion des
déchets radioactifs et ça concerne aussi
et surtout notre région là aussi c'est
une impasse parce que les piscines
d'entreposage des déchets radioactifs de
la hague sont en effet déjà rempli à 93%
et c'est bien la construction d'un
nouveau site d'entreposage de ces
déchets qui va forcément s'imposer
et justement il en est question à
belleville sur loire dans le cher
même si edf assure que pour l'instant
rien n'est encore décidé merci beaucoup
ou pire pour cet éclairage très complet
merci vous